every so often I I come on Twitter right
uh and uh every so often I see Emily
tweezing most of the time it's
strawberry themed or something about
some Shoujo anime you're watching I'm
I'm fine with that I'm fine with that
and then every time you have a food take
I just like I just have to like close
Twitter for the day
my days
okay
let's uh okay I'm out the one that comes
to mind most recently I can't believe
we're starting this off and you're
coming and Swinging like minute one yeah
you've been there for like how long have
you been in Japan now oh God
[Music]
oh yeah
in like 10 months
we've been hanging out for like 10
months we've like lost all
preconceptions of just like having to be
nice when coming on the show or
something so you know
reoccurring yeah so at this point you
you know yeah you have to fit in yeah
he's having [__] takes and also we roast
each other okay the kitty gloves are off
so I'm ready to battle um so do you
wanna so one thing that comes to mind is
uh your tier list of noodles
let's start off so did you not see
Emily's tier list of uh like Japanese
noodles no I don't know what what did
you say she tweeted it out so Emily how
would you like to rank
at the top we have udon that's cap
I need diet is here with me because he
agrees
here it's just number one okay number
one is it on yeah number two soba
okay
go on number three skimming okay
number four Ramen okay and then dead
last is Stillman okay well dead last
Solomon that's that's an obviously
they're kind of like you know like other
noodles there's ramen noodles right just
in different ways do you want to explain
what Simon is because I'm sure a lot of
follow me is like I mean for one you
usually only eat it in the summer
usually it's like chilled um it's like
the very clear almost like rice noodles
I don't remember exactly what they made
ramen noodles I don't think they are I'm
[__] dumb they're not they're really
late yeah yeah I think they're kind of
like rice noodles where it's very thin
almost transparent white noodles yeah
you usually have with like a very very
simple like soy sauce based thing you
you have it in the summer as like a
lunch like a very light lunch it's the
one where you know you've seen it's like
running on the river yeah those things
suck it's awful okay and that is that is
like universally normal yeah it's like
the weakest noodles it's like all my
home all my homies hate Soma you know
but you know there are there is like
maybe like once every couple of Summers
where I'm like I could kind of go for a
salmon lunch right now that's me with
Ramen
uh imagine Ramen you'd quadrupled the
thickness and it couldn't absorb any of
the flavor yeah it's like it's like
cement it's so thin so okay okay look I
you like I like udon yeah but the fact
that it's your number one upsets you
know what the fact that you have two
noodles above skin man is like
triggering okay well I haven't had
enough to give it took the inverse of
hers
yeah yeah yeah because like I remember
when you posted that list I was like wow
you have literally posted this listen
opposite order almost I think I think in
the original tweet you posted Superman
at last and I was like Ramen was like
okay
it's just like I'm never no no I don't
think ramen's bad don't think that last
means bad yeah okay second to last in
this case right it's just the one that I
prefer the least okay like if you gave
me a menu yeah I will immediately gloss
over Robin like I won't even like okay
okay explain to me why udon is your
number one that's what I want to know
what is it about Udon that speaks to you
the noodles are nice and thick and chewy
and tasty and then the broth to like
go with the thickness of the noodles the
broth is nice and light why why are you
saying it's just like the worst mix of
every every Japanese noodle
Curry and it's like oh this is curry
with cement no that's that's too that's
too heavy but the the udon broth I love
a good Kitsune udon where you got that
like tofu skin I get that and it's nice
and then you get a little side of like
tempura I think the most I've ever eaten
noodle was when I had that stomach flu
because it's very light and easy to
digest yeah um but like if I'm in a if
I'm a healthy boy I'm not going for udon
yeah oh yeah udon is usually for me it's
like the sick food yeah if I wanted
something I guess light I'd probably
just go for like Sober Sober to me is
like lighter than udon yeah
yeah no yeah so it was good but for me
udon's like a comfort food you know what
it's because I think so I used to live
in San Diego it was really hard to find
really good udon right right so now I
feel like I've just developed a cream
I realized that they were like the guys
were like I'm gonna roast you for your
shitty opinions I was like I don't have
one but then I realized no there's one
that hurt me there's one that really
okay okay all right guys so there's this
I think I know yeah that's just you yeah
you know
there's this place in Hokkaido right
there's it's called it's called soup
curry mod mug oh yeah yeah God like
God's guards here this is like it's soup
curry right if you haven't had a soup
curry it's literally it's not hard to
figure out it's curry in a soup form
yeah and this place is
this place is insane it's it do the
amount of spices they put in there if
you look on Google dude it's crazy if
you go to Toya you got to go here it's
the spot
and Emily was like it's fine and I was
like no it's fine it's just like the
heavens themselves
they would rival anything question out
of 10 what would you have given it we're
gonna eat
what it was good you said it was good it
was fine usually is like six
no it was good I like none of it was bad
I just wouldn't travel an hour for it I
would I would
some meals are worth traveling an hour
for in my defense the breakfast we had
that day was monstrous if you remember
right right I feel like I don't know
I need it I need to try again I make
room I make room all right yeah yeah
because you only ate like half your
breakfast and you were like I gotta save
them for soup curry yeah I mean that was
smart yeah yeah I've every time I've
gone to Hokkaido I've kind of made it
like a thing where I'm always I always
try to go there because it's probably
one of my favorite food spots in all of
Japan it's so good it's so good it's
cheap as well it's too cheap and he goes
up to this is when I knew this man was
the goat not only is it one to ten it
was like one to Thirty or Twenty spice
levels yeah and it was like five onwards
is habanero I'm like how how can we go
higher yeah
that's what impressed me about his spice
levels because there are some Japanese
chains that have like a ridiculous
amount of spice levels right they don't
mean [__] for the most places because
you all that matters is that when you
get to like the higher spice levels
you're basically just eating curry
powder yeah yeah when you have an area
you're like oh we were using real
Peppers yeah yeah yeah we care yeah I'm
like what's level 30 just [__]
cyanide it's just a ball of Hearts yeah
it's just I like spice food I get like
four or five it's pretty damn spicy like
I can't imagine pushing it yeah exactly
it's I was impressed as a Thai person I
was like oh this is like real spice it's
real good spice as well do you just not
like strong flavors then because maybe
you don't you know what maybe because I
I can't handle spicy right I don't like
super sweet stuff
I don't like super sour stuff what do
you like I like it good cardboard you
are an enigma oh I like salty okay well
you like salty that's everything that's
true I think I just don't like I think I
have the palette of like a 65 year old
woman or six year old girl
a sensitive palette let's say yes
because maybe like you put like Superman
and ramen last which is our like I'm
pretty sure our favorites oh yeah 100
yeah
um just because of like the nice thick
broth no I think it's just the nice
strong flavors if I get Ramen I take out
the meat
Titus
no I give it to Titus he likes the meat
oh what I admit
the pork sometimes in the broth in the
ramen is really cheap really bad it can
be but you still eat it sometimes if
it's done right it's like my favorite
part of the ramen honestly because a lot
of the times the broth is built around
that yeah so it's like it's the broth
perfectly matches it it's called child
shoes
the broth has enough meaty flavor for me
and anything like the I like either rice
with like meat on it or I like meaty
broth with my noodles but if I have meat
on it it's too much I need to take that
I hate I hate it because I've had these
exact same arguments with Sydney because
she looked at you I'm like I I saw the
tear list and I looked in and just like
looked at it in disgust and I showed
Sydney and she was like yes that's my
tear list as well I was like
[Laughter]
he also ranks oh no I think he ranks I
think for him it's udon soba it's given
wait no or skim and udon soba yeah no
he's I remember him saying skimming was
his favorite yeah yeah which is kids
which is good that's correct valid yeah
that that is the correct opinion that is
the correct answer so which sober do you
prefer cold sober okay thank God thank
God I'm a hot guy really I hate that
[__] cold
I don't know if this is I don't know
where this comes from in my head I'm
like man it just doesn't feel like a
meal unless it's hot
it cannot be dinner in my mind is that
why you can't eat sushi for dinner yeah
yeah it's often why I don't eat sushi
right yeah I will have it there are some
sushis that you won't go out of your way
right yeah I'd rather have sushi for
lunch all right yeah because in my head
something about it like I don't know I
don't know what kind of just have a side
Suites
yeah yeah again like I I do eat sushi
for dinner sometimes it's rare but a lot
of the times like I do not understand
cold soup I think cold soup is a crime
against soup I think no no no no no no
no no
a cold pumpkin soup if somebody offers
me cold soup I'm like just [__] keep
it it's it's all dependent on the
environment man of course like a lot of
French people are like what do you what
the [__] do you mean
today sometimes you just get like a nice
refreshing cold soup as a starter and it
just like hot drinks when it's a hot day
I like cold drinks on cold days yeah I
don't know how I for some for some
reason when I drink hot tea this this
just felt like an AI generated yeah I
like hot drinks on hot days
maybe you feel the same way but when I
drink a hot drink on a hot day for some
reason I feel like it cools me down what
yeah I don't know why you call me wait
wait repeat what you just said so I can
fully it doesn't make any sense wait so
you you feel like a hot drink the hot
drink cools you down but it heats up
your body yeah but I I think it's like I
don't know something about it it feels
kind of kind of right see I I kind of
get what you mean because like if you
have a hot tea okay because I prefer
eating ice creams I was a [__] same
brain cell right again I remember colder
the day is the more I'm like [__] no
that's different I I actually wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait how's that
different that's different
appeal in eating cold ice cream on a
cold day because you know it's gonna
stay colder so it's not right because
you don't you don't see it no
yeah because okay yeah it like it holds
its shape longer so you get that it's at
its peak ice cream I don't feel it
tastes better on a cold today I I I
think both ways because I actually like
don't like eating ice cream on a hot day
I I know that sounds counterintuitive
but to me on a hot day I want something
refreshing and when I have like a thick
ice cream that's one the opposite of
refreshing
um and two it's just gonna melt faster
yeah right and on a cold day I'm
probably gonna be less thirsty and it's
just something nice about having like a
nice
thick ice cream like a Hokkaido ice
cream on a Winter's day next to the snow
I don't know I just like all ice cream
at all periods because ice cream is the
best [__] dessert
this is like when you guys laughed at me
we went to the restaurant and it was
like this really fancy restaurant and
everyone was getting these desserts that
were extremely like it was like it's a
mushroom caved in as a chocolate truffle
and then Joey's like I'll have the I'll
have the falombe uh flipped inside out
and uh
I have ice cream
I'm a single scoop of ice cream
of vanilla ice cream yeah I remember and
everyone laughed and I ordered it
because everyone was going on this
tirade of extremely extravagant desserts
did dessert was really really [__]
good and they put like they put effort
into designing these really really
intricate desserts yeah and they looked
they all not only looked ecstatic but
they tasted really really good
um and and then no because I get it
because it's like if it's at like a bog
standard like you know run-of-the-mill
restaurant that has desserts then I will
also opt to get like a single scoop of
ice screen but if you're at like a fancy
restaurant or like a restaurant that has
like I don't need this desserts that
actually are crafted and uh unique then
yeah I'm gonna try it out like I'm not a
huge dessert person but I'm like okay
that looks kind of unique I'm like the
complete opposite of you because if if I
go to a normal place and they just like
have bog standard desserts I'm just not
gonna have dessert the only the only
reason I'll go out of my way to have
dessert if it's if it's like a little
bit extravagant a little bit yeah
something special it's like the steak
right it's like uh you know in every
restaurant like steak is the indication
of how you can how good your restaurant
is right if you cook a steak yeah same
with ice cream you can give me good ice
cream then your desserts must be pretty
[__] good if you can get a vanilla
ice cream but you never order anything
but vanilla ice cream would you know
we're back
I consider something Connor only because
it is two things vanilla ice cream and
Tiramisu that's like anything else on
the menu is just like well I like it
disgusting what's that uh what's that
The Italian Dish called the one where
it's like cream and like oh I like creme
brulee no no
yeah that's good too